ta madame marie-christine dalloz pour le
groupe l'est républicain merci monsieur
le président le projet de loi de
finances pour 2016 sera votée dans
quelques instants après de longs sévère
de longs débats en séance publique
monsieur le premier ministre nous ne
sommes pas rassurés par ce budget
l'objectif de déficit pour 2016 par est
inatteignable des effectifs de l'état
repartent à la hausse le taux des
prélèvements obligatoires ne baisse pas
et les dépenses continuent d'augmenter
voilà la réalité un budget sans courage
qui ne traitent pas les vrais sujets et
un budget sans cap qui met la poussière
sous le tapis
début décembre début septembre le
gouvernement a adressé à 8 millions de
contribuables dont la fiscalité évoluer
un courrier leur annonçant la baisse de
leur impôt sur la forme monsieur le
premier ministre
alors que vous prônez la télédéclaration
et le télépaiement pouvez vous nous
indiquer le coût de cet envoi massif sur
le fond un salarié qui bénéficiait
jusqu'en 2013 des heures supplémentaires
défiscalisées n'a pas vu baisser son
impôt depuis votre arrivée au pouvoir
une personne retraitée qui a eu trois
enfants et qui bénéficie à ce titre
d'une majoration de 10 % défiscaliser
n'a pas vu son impôt baissé depuis votre
arrivée au pouvoir
un couple avec trois enfants qui a subi
la baisse du quotient familial n'a pas
vu son impôt baissé depuis votre arrivée
au pouvoir vous baisser les impôts de
certains vous augmentez les impôts de
tous les autres monsieur le ministre
pensez vous que cette baisse de la
fiscalité via une revalorisation de la
décote à faire oublier aux françaises et
aux français
votre déroute fiscal vous procéder à des
réajustements dans la perspective des
prochaines échéances électorales
hasard de calendrier la majorité des
bonnes nouvelles concernera la praye
les français ne sont pas dupes ils ont
compris que vous faites de la
récupération politique
monsieur le ministre quel est le coût de
l'envoi de ces courriers pour le
contribuable et sommes nous déjà en
précampagne électorale
officiellement
merci madame dalloz la parole est à
monsieur michel sapin ministres des
finances et des comptes publics
merci au président mesdames messieurs
les députés madame dalloz
je ne sais pas qui est en campagne
électorale mais je vous conseillerais
d'avoir des arguments sur un sujet aussi
sérieux qui soit plus proche de la
réalité alors parlons des choses simples
est-ce que les impôts des français vont
baisser dans le budget qui est en cours
de discussion votre nom est d'un
ridicule total car chacun sait que les
impôts vont baisser pour les entreprises
9 milliards de baisse qu'ils vont
baisser pour les ménages 2 milliards de
baisse après trois milliards de baisse
cette année
madame dalloz au lieu de parler de je ne
sais trop quel jeu je ne sais trop
quelle paix comment vous dites mouvement
que nous avons effectivement signalé à
ceux qui ont investi en bénéficier
parler de baisse
n'ayez pas peur de la réalité quand les
impôts baisse dites le il baisse dit le
ils baissent clairement pour 12 millions
12 millions de foyers fiscaux sur 17
millions voient leurs impôts baisser et
une partie de ceux à qui vous aviez
augmenter les impôts
par exemple en supprimant la demi part
des veuves cela oui nous allons leur
permet de ne plus en payer de fermer
cette parenthèse que vous aviez ouvert
en faisant payer des gens modestes alors
que vous épargner ce qu'ils avaient
beaucoup plus d'argent nous n'avons une
politique de justice ceux qui peuvent
payer plus
pay plus mais ce que vous aviez vous
même et nous mêmes à la suite appelé à
contribuer pour lutter contre les
déficits a eu aujourd'hui nous rendons
une part des efforts qu'ils ont faits
voilà la justice
voilà la réalité et grâce en particulier
à l'amendement de melun pires bonne
comme l'a très bien expliqué monsieur
christian eckert
nous allons également vous allez le
parlement ici également baisser les
impôts
qu un certain nombre de personnes en
particulier âgées qui se sont vu
augmenter à cause de vous merci monsieur
le ministre
la parole est à madame geneviève gauche